[Music]
many conservatives so the brexit
referendum and Donald Trump's 2016
victory as used for correctives it was
time to push back the argument went
against the overreach of unaccountable
international bureaucracies such as the
European Union and the UN maybe even
NATO has become obsolete but can we
really go back to an age of sovereign
nation-states not really for example 10
million u.s. flags are imported into the
United States from China every year and
the title integrated global economy
needs shared rules although reforms of
many international organizations are
needed Western democracies cannot
disengage if they're to keep the worst
authoritarians at bay also the age of
sovereign nation-states is mostly a myth
throughout this history
Europe was marked by efforts to
reconcile diversity and unity through
Federalist projects such as the Holy
Roman Empire or the Hanseatic League
those long predate the creation of the
modern nation-state in the late 19th
century globalism is does not a historic
aberration nationalism is to learn more
about my take on nationalism and
globalism check the link in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI
[Music]